nous recevrons maintenant dans cette
édition de 13h un ami de la famille mais
c'est un ami à vous aussi que vous
rencontrer régulièrement le dimanche
soir sur antenne 2 il s'agit du
commissaire maigret alias jean richard
qui n'est pas venu seul avec madame
mégret qui est aussi madame jean richard
c'est parfaitement clair
alors jean richard vous allez fêter en
octobre 21 ans au 21 ans de maigret
c'est à dire que je commence la semaine
prochaine c'est à dire exactement le 4
juillet nous 80 8e maigret 4la 21 ans
que ça dure
alors 88 épisodes alors c'est un
personnage attachant c'est moi qu'on
puisse jamais prétendre cohabitent j'ai
voulu le faire parce que qu'est-ce que
j'étais pour les gens avant les
migraines j'étais le gars de champignol
rôle que j'avais à créer avec roger
pierre et jean marc thibault c'est moral
si j'étais j'étais un peu le colis le
coluche paysans de l'époque sur est la
pire depuis et bien je suis ravi car un
jour je me suis regardé dans une glace
puis je me suis dit mais est ce que tu
vas champignol ise jusqu'à la qualité
jour puisqu'il n'y aurait pas dans la
littérature française
un personnage large en épaule qui
pourrait interpréter faire prêter et je
venais d'apprendre que ben arma avait
proposé les maigret à la télévision
l'homme avait été pris et comme claude
est un très bon copain j'ai tout de
suite téléphoné j'ai dit écoute je sais
que tu vas faire les belles gré je ne
sais pas si tu as ton bonhomme mais je
me mets sur les rangs et le faible et le
fait que le garçon pignol se propose
pour jouer megrahi doit rien encore et
puis sans doute pas parce que quand j'ai
repris l'appareil j'ai entendu et
pourquoi pas voilà que c'est venu vous
décrivez avec un vrai comédien vous
voyons plus vous assisté à la scène avec
le téléphone à l'homme si vous y étiez
reste pas toujours d'accord avec maigret
oui vous vous disputez avait clairement
fait que j'ai une façon très facile de
trouver les intrigues ce que je lise
romans d'avant
on a l'habitude de dire que quand un
personnage comme ça est tellement
attachant et vous colle à la peau
moralité on ne fait plus rien d'autre
c'est exigeant la fin je veux dire que
c'est exact une colle à la peau pour
l'anecdote je peux vous dire par exemple
que quand je passe dans les rues à paris
les agents de la circulation mettre la
main alors qu'ils font
il ne faut pas trop bien je trouve ça
très sympathique
je crois d'ailleurs que si mais nous a
voulu que maigret soit sympathique car
je crois sincèrement que maigret c'est
l'homme qui aurait aimé être si meinau
mais ça il vous l'a dit lui où vous le
supposez je le suppose
j'ai beaucoup lu le dit mais je connais
en fait je suis allé voir si mais n'ont
joué le lendemain du 1er mai grèce et si
les marques et étaient très gentils nous
a fait une façon formidable c'est un
maniaque insensé le premier travail de
psy mais non il m'a pas dit là il a eu
une table très épaisse dans laquelle il
ya des taille crayon il a il a deux
boîtes de crayons de 22,20 crayon chaque
passe tous ses crayons pas prévu et
alors si la femme de ménage
le matin a mis les crayons à gauche au
lieu de les mettre à droite et demi est
une journée n'est pas celle du travail
ou bien vous voulez peut-être une petite
lichette de maigret et pourquoi pas bon
alors en attendant le 80 huitième
épisode voici un extrait du 84e
ça s'appelait maigret l'homme de la rue
yoga les faits quand y en a peu le mec
là choix qui n'est pas bien de 6 500
fois du jaudy que je suis trop bien
c'est pas normal
tu crois que c'est un médecin j'en sais
rien en tout cas ils feraient mieux de
consulter ses confrères il n'a pas l'air
bien non c'est pas normal monsieur
monsieur
bonjour patron meurtre et aucun doute
la victime se trouvait au volant de sa
voiture ce sont autant qu'ils ont
prévenu et monsieur madame pays pourrait
en bois et puis ils ont été intrigués
par le côté immobile du chauffeur ils
ont ouvert la portière
le corps a basculé à la bouffe à la
commissaire bonjour docteur simple soin
de vos confrères
et oui comme ici à personne et à l'abri
du pire quelles sont vos premières
conclusions alors demandé à madame et
gray madame jean richard c'est vous qui
avez sollicité les auteurs de la série
pour venir travailler avec votre
autrement et je vais répondre mais
répond non jamais je vais répondre pour
être parce que madame mégret a été la
troisième la monnaie est pauvre miss
teen france junior et puis après
dominique blanchard qui en effet 4 et à
la dirm non puisque je suis pas dans
tous les autres épisodes je vois pas
pourquoi on engage au pied de marché due
qu'à marcel cravenne le jour où il a eu
à faire à maigret cela fait pas mal
il ya dix ans la part de madame migré il
a dit à parma mais si on essayait annick
com indique avait tourné avec moi pas
mal de films avant l'époque où des films
parce qu'avant de faire les 80 numéros
j'ai fait 1 603 comptait pas très bon
d'accord mais c'est comme ça la maison
et vous coupe la parole vous pouvez
remplacer une personne de temps en temps
en place une lui impose presque dans la
vie vous êtes aussi gentil que vous
l'êtes dans le feuilleton
oui oui oui c'est à dire pour moi ça ne
me change pas parce que vraiment sur le
plateau dans le rôle de megan est
vraiment beau brun à la maison j'ai tout
à fait à l'aise elle a même fait je ne
sais pas quand mais vous ne faites pas
là vous ne dormez pas sur le plateau
la vraie cuisine là bas vous faites la
différence entre votre maison oui c'est
un peu mon font parfois lui j'ai appris
quelque chose c'est que malgré cuisine
beaucoup mieux que moi
la requête de moussaoui la plante on
salive en regardant maigret vous la
faites vous la fête de la vigne
alors si hier on termine jeanrichard
avec des photos de la mer de sable parc
de loisirs de d'ermenonville c'est son
25e anniversaire vous étiez un
précurseur en la matière parce que
maintenant il ya les concurrents ben oui
j'allais vous dire c'est que ça fait
plaisir mais commémorer le 25ème
anniversaire dans ce sens que l'on
s'aperçoit finalement que le parc
d'attractions attractive de la mer de
sable a été le premier du genre dans
l'art construit dans la région
parisienne premier du genre vous avez
maintenant des imitateurs qui sont
costauds alors il ya mirapolis et qui
bientôt il ya les américains qui départ
là alors vous allez vous allez résister
vous allez avant de rejoindre bien voir
écoutez je me suis installé à
ermenonville en 1954 en 1956 j'ai créé
le premier parc zoologique privé de
france et quelques années plus tard je
prenais le coup de foudre pour cette
étendue sablonneuse du lieu-dit la mer
de sable où les parisiens venaient déjà
y pique [ __ ] et dimanche alors ça
marche depuis 25 ans et j'ai décidé d'y
monter un parc attractif barré sur les
cinq parties du monde
un sous titre en était le tour du monde
en 80 minutes pour parodier un roman
célèbre cumul et puis d'ailleurs les
attractions il attaque du train le rang
sur la grande roue le drap le g c'est
l'agencé 25 ha de sable d'un seul tenant
il n'y avait pas l'eau et cette année il
fallait long à la mer de sable
or il y en a à cause de l'équipe
technique qui a construit cette
instruction à sensation nous avons
baptisé copieusement la rivière sauvage
du coup c'est à dire que sur une rivière
démonter une vague mais les spectateurs
assis sur des baquets pneumatiques vous
circulez j'invite tous les jeunes et
leurs parents à se rendre là bas je
rappelle que le prix de l'entrée basse
et 48 francs pour ce prix là bas vous
avez droit à toutes les attractions et
les spectacles gratuits à l'intérieur
sauf la restauration va bien national
merci de votre visite patron pas trop de
ces patients différente
madame grès madame jean richard merci à
vous et à bientôt pour ce 88e 88 100e
épisode
voilà vous êtes trop gentil